boy haven't you turned into the rich
little of useless impressions I mean
from the way I'm like Donnie Brasco I'm
in too deep how deep do your impressions
go like do you do Eddy the produce guy I
do Elephant Boy a little bit you still
with that same girl no no oh yeah she's
in in jail you've got tan mom would you
do the part of the song as tan mom where
she's kind of arguing with herself
you don't talk about I take off my
clothes which I wouldn't do what it
isn't there several different tan moms
like like she starts out the song was
like later on she's like I wouldn't take
which I wanted yeah she's yelling at you
whose ass and same with Jeff the drunk
right yeah wait a second Jeff what are
you doing you [ __ ] my [ __ ] why are
you giving me the finger no way I'm
getting to you because I build up people
are coming use your head say is the call
is it word-for-word a call for him last
week all right
I'm followed this girl on the periscope
she's like a rapper and she was walking
in the city and she did a rap about me
want me to said
to the show now Jeff we're good